Hello I'm Jane Carter and I'm director of
coaching for hope. I think the possibility
of FIFA for world cup benefitting Africa is
definitely there. And I think the key really,
my point of view, my pont of view, is to invest
in the people who love football, who follow
football. Football is such a big force for
changing Africa if it's used positively. So
I think the key thing is investing in the
coaching infrastructure. Giving people a chance
to get out there and play. And focus on the
people rather than the buildings. Then the
whole continent hopefully can really get something
out of this fantastic event.
[pause]
Will that do?
[laughter]
Ok.